I'm right hi I'm Seth and I'm Jerry I
didn't get to be anyone else why would
people want you to be someone else we're
gonna talk about the first 300 right now
because you know 300 rise of an empire
just came out and that people if you
guys haven't seen it
they all died yeah someone ruined that
movie for me I was at Chuck E Cheese and
this guy named Colton was there and
Colton was like oh I read the 300 comic
book and they're making a movie about it
it's cool it's cool cuz you know like
it's one of those stories where all the
heroes die at the end and I was like why
the [ __ ] would you tell me that and he's
like because it's in the history books
people already know I'm like well do I
look like I read history you
[ __ ] this is a true story cuz I
thought yeah but then I took home like a
bunch of tickets and I saved for a
bigger prize I didn't realize how much I
really liked this movie until I watched
it for like the fifth time yeah like
every time I watched it I said what a
lot of people said like oh it's it's
there's no story there's no characters
just a bunch of visuals and then when I
watched it this time I was like this
film is [ __ ] brilliant not just
because of the action and visuals but
it's like there's a narrator telling the
story and he's telling like a legendary
tale and he's talking about the times of
battle you know imagine like when
warriors tell stories that's what you're
gonna see and it's cool that's all in
slow motion because you're like telling
the tale that way it's done through the
imagery well exactly I mean that's
that's what's always worked for me about
this movies is because it is a soldier's
poem essentially it's like it's exactly
the kind of story a soldier were told
around I can't fire to rile his troops
up first
you know it's like that's what Beowulf
is you know those stories even in
mythology and stuff were always big and
macho and you know crazy like that so it
never bothered me that it was an action
heavy you know warrior movie I think
this film captured the essence of just
storytelling in general and especially
from that time because I'm sure they
didn't have this thing you know
Gollum looking things and big giants and
back in the day but that's how they told
the stories
yeah to make it seem more theatrical and
more epic than it actually was
but I thought I had a really cool like
video game feel to it I was going into
this watching it I just saw it and it's
been like how many years since I came
out because I always just thought it was
gonna be stupid action flick this is all
blood and gore and that's what I was
expecting but I actually really loved
the characters I didn't think it was it
lacked any story at all sometimes
narrators and movies can be really weird
and sometimes they can be a little bit
out of place or here like that guys
talking again but this narrator actually
it flowed really well and his voice
really fit the story so the way it
carried through I was so entertained and
I actually loved it
what I really loved about it especially
what the narrator does really well okay
I've seen a [ __ ] ton of gerard butler
movies after this film watching it again
the other day was like this is gonna
make gerard butler a star was this
[ __ ] movie and you're watching and
you're like i can see totally why like
everything he says is a [ __ ] quote
normally in a movie like this there
tends to be some supporting character
people like more but like no it's
Leonidas man let's see you walk out
thinking about he's talked about the
most the way they everything they
describe about him Gerard Butler
embodies all that yeah I know he's like
when he enters the screen you're like I
can see what everyone's talking about
and I you know it's like that's an easy
character in other movies to have the
kind of bland but has so much charisma
and he really commands this green
whatever is most something about just
just faith to that you can see not only
a warrior but he really does miss his
wife don't the whole thing he's really
thinking about all that and then at the
end when he's about to die that he just
screams that out you know and she
doesn't even know she doesn't you know
cuz he left just being like yeah okay
she was like I love you and mr. he's
like alright bye you know but that was
not the Attic I mean he had to be a
soldier and motionless at that time
there I'm saying that's that's what it
would have looked like to her but to him
he knew this I
she understood she understood shouting
when he put on the small leather
Underpants I know I just mean like he
wasn't just like a strong character the
whole time
oh it wasn't OneNote that's right that's
the things you're our Butler brings a
certain amount of you know deficit
performance note that it's like written
deeply but he does have a lot of life
going yeah there's a lot of layers do
yeah there's a lot of lighters too boy
there's a lot of lawyers in this movie
yeah it's like it's quarks moving it's
not super spelled out you know it's not
a deep film necessarily but you can tell
that he embodies characters the point of
if someone else were to play his part I
don't think I woulda liked it as much
because they probably would have been
the typical like I am Caine what I say
goes
that is all and you know but I love the
way he was written like yeah like he's a
real leader in this film like he loves
his people he knows how to treat them he
knows when a discipline and he knows how
to [ __ ] look like he motivates you
don't wanna fight a battle my favorite
wine like going off when he said like
why it's because when Xerxes was like I
would kill any of my people you know
just he was like well I would die for
any of my people just that I don't know
that wine just kind of define his
character and that's was Erick sees that
you know it's a funny bill first time
you see him you're like what a drag
and he's supposed to be like this
intimidating guy I think some people
take it as intimidating and some people
take it as kind of a joke he's obsessed
with getting people to kneel
that means most of his lines he's huge I
mean he's like eight or nine feet tall
whatever they say he's gigantic he's
vain he he's prideful you know like he's
you know he is homosexual
well maybe partly but because of what
you said I just think just think about
it I'm sure he's probably bisexual but
yeah he's gotta be but you know that
kind of a character he's that he's the
and he's the horrible King you know he's
like I am a guy he's drunk his own
kool-aid he thinks he's the greatest
thing you know it's like Leonidas is a
leader and a king but he's not struttin
around like check me out guys like you
don't know he's the kind of guy you
don't want to lead you you know like
look you know different from all those
soldiers they all look the same the fact
that he looked the same as all about
unity yeah those are cool and he
wouldn't lead the battles you know who
made him this [ __ ] he was a king but he
was always the first one in that was
badass man and I once see the first time
they I watch this and I'm like you know
there's not like there's barely any kind
of action like the first 45 minutes of
this film yeah you know people think
about it like a few ships crash they
kick some people into the well and then
hang out a bit well they kick some
people into the pit but then the first
action scene is the one where they're
slowing going to the slow-motion fast
motion with Gerard Butler's [ __ ]
everyone up even though it's right now
helmet you could tell that strop Butler
under there well you know he got that
you got that big old Greek beer yeah
like that but yeah and that's the other
thing too the action I remember the
first time I saw this and you know I
mean now everyone's kind of aimed this
movie's action but it's shot and with
all those the speed ramping and the fat
slow motion like that was really crazy
at the time in it and it still holds up
now is not any cool what watching again
yeah and whatever thing is really cool
it's like I felt the power of the
story's message by the end of this film
and I never felt it before until the
first four times I watched because when
they die I finally got it cuz he's he's
tellin the night before he's pretty much
saying look we're all gonna die but
we're gonna do it for a reason because
this is what's gonna get us to rise like
he knows what will come from them die
like it's gonna be a powerful story
that's why he sends the soldier home to
be like hey you tell people about us and
make up what happens when we all die
which is pretty much what do you do why
do you think sacrifice in general it's
just really one and that's their whole
dream is like in the
the best way to go out is gloriously in
battle with your brothers at your side
so you know again they're cool they cool
one thing I found distracting and I
think it was only distracting because
this guy is much bigger now more
respected Michael FAAST meant when he
said Oh awesome and get the blonde guy
who's like who fights in the shadows
okay
yeah when Michael Fassbender showed up I
was like this Michael Fassbender and the
way he was behaving I was like Michael
Fassbender seems like he's acting and
that distracts oh I disagree I he
disagreed with you to the sort of he's
the guy who's really enjoying all this
but I believed it Oh Sally close your
ears you don't want to have mommy and
daddy fighting right now okay today we
can't do retakes
there's nothing okay yeah cos he
believed it like he's he is that soldier
who is involved and almost amped about I
believed him when I first saw it but now
that I've seen Michael Fassbender in a
lot of roles for some reason he was
distracted you know he's magneto in
x-men first class the guy with the big
hairy dick and shame what else was there
inglorious basterds as the British
interpreter journalist yeah it was
reporting journalists in Seoul yeah yeah
12 years a slave
yeah you know talking about Michael
Fassbender movies tends to Boris Alec I
mean I guess x-men of all them the
closest to this movie
yeah but I'm basically saying that like
it was I mean he didn't do a bad job by
any means it was just a little
distracting this time around as opposed
to when I saw through our Butler's
character I just bought the Unitas I
never thought about it but what what you
mean is that for example Bryan Cranston
is a great actor but now after Breaking
Bad everyone's just gonna be distracted
because in Godzilla they're like it's
Heisenberg
actually Sally it's more like Breaking
Bad and then you go back and revisit
malcolm in the middle and you're like
huh I feel like he's acting a little bit
in this one he's playing more Bravo
I know what you need I know I can't they
agree because I don't know Michael Bosse
matters yeah tell the audience who some
movies Michael Fassbender is me because
I know who is the other thing I like 300
is that it is one of those movies you
know anything with warriors you always
have a number of them and they all have
different personalities but 300 just as
a whole piece I felt like was cast
really well because there's not a whole
lot of you know gradient between the
caliber I don't know exactly how to say
it but like oh there were no actors I
found distracting nobody no there was
nobody who was bad you know it's like I
liked everybody no more so Britt yeah
everyone was on the left how did you
feel about that Sally is so beautiful to
watch all I wanted to do why couldn't I
have been an extra there you go oh yeah
you got who else I got David Wain
openSUSE he was in Windows 8 characters
delia uh dealios he's the guy with 100
yeah he wasn't water he's I remember now
I'm you know I loved in this film was
the cop of the cap the one who was I
know the one who was the guy who lost
his son that guy did a [ __ ] job what
he like loses his son yeah it starts
[ __ ] up all those people and then was
like crying and screaming I was like
that seemed so real yeah I was watching
that I was like damn when I would give
to have a scene like that but on my demo
reel click on this link below to see
Sally's demo reel yeah action visuals
were great yeah oh yeah I don't think
you could talk about 300 without talking
about the way it's shot because partly
because I mean Zack Snyder is mr.
visuals in a lot of ways
visionary director I haven't read the
book but I've perused it and it really
seems like they did a fantastic job of
making it look exactly like those
drawing because every shot is is
composed and picturesque even you know
when people are talking and it's just
coverage like well then everything looks
incredible like not to discredit Zack
Snyder because I think he did a great
job of this film but oh yeah real fast
music was bombed to a tipping woods axe
neither is he gets all the credit
usually but I'm thinking the visual
effects department has a lot more to do
with this then Zack Snyder going I want
it to look like the comic book well yes
I know but I'm talking about framing
like just the way it shots afraid I
think it's a synthesis of the two
because this is another movie like Sin
City where they stop I'm not talking
about your thing Jerry I would say my
home thing I'm piggybacking on you
because I said this is another movie
like Sin City what that's I am I am
grabbing that idea and embellishing it
this movie is like Sin City because they
shot it all against green screens and
they painted in all the backgrounds so I
think it's a synthesis of the two you
know the visual effects
I'm sure Zack Snyder had something to do
with all that framing and when to slow
down and speed up judging by all of his
movies having a similar style I think he
has a matter wrong vision alright boys
boys Z snide yeah you know it's funny
about Jerry he's my best friend but if
there's anyone I [ __ ] with the most it's
him and the one who can least tell well
[ __ ] with someone we can't get our
say in because you're just like oh no no
way no no and then you you aren't joking
but you seriously do caught us off when
we're trying to be a little bit serious
but what we're saying
I guess is weird to give a consent I
owned this movie on DVD so I guess I
already bought it on DVDs this is what
happens think it's definitely worth
owning it's it's a fun one to pull out
you know it's not it's not too light not
too heavy it's thrilling it's a good
time you know I definitely I I do own it
so yeah
I would buy it oh I would also buy oh
I'm sorry
anyone here why don't you [ __ ] with me
right now thanks for watching oh there's
a button here you can subscribe to the
channel
Sally inserts extra and pretending to be
awkward but actually liking you did you
hear what he just said